president biden wants to take your guns
and his reasoning is pretty simple
president biden is arguing that the
second amendment
is outdated because if he really wanted
to take you out
he could just nuke you the second
amendment from the day it was passed
limited the type of people could own a
gun and what type of weapon you could
own
you couldn't buy cannon those who say
the blood of the
the blood of patriots you know and all
the stuff about how we're gonna have to
move against the government well the
tree of liberty is not water in the
blood of patriots what's happened is
that there are never been if you wanted
to think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some nuclear
weapons
the point is that there's always been
the ability to limit rationally limit
the type of weapon that can be owned and
who can own it
and you think of the problem in the
blood and you think that then the
and the jefferson and uh who huh
huh what were we talking about his his
argument runs into a problem of course
because on the one hand he's telling you
that your ar-15 is completely powerless
and so there's no reason for you to have
it but he's he's saying that within the
context
of telling you how your ar-15 is much
too powerful and that's why he's got to
take it away from you but the government
is using much subtler weapons against
all of us
it is turning the irs against christians
it is turning radical ideologies against
our kids and it is ignoring the
development of
bioweapons in wuhan china
under the state department of hillary
clinton new leaked email show you know
what i have to say
hands up don't nuke i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knoll show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
king loser who says it's hard to win an
argument with a smart person
but it is impossible to win an argument
with a stupid person
this is very very true i have noticed
this
you want some consistency from your
people at least you know
broadly speaking but when someone
changes his mind
that's actually a sign of intelligence
if he had the wrong opinion it's good
that he has the right opinion
you can never do that with a stupid
person this is
good advice to go along with what we
said yesterday do not wrestle with pigs
you will both get dirty and he will like
it
especially in chaotic crazy times such
as ours really makes you want to invest
in physical gold that's why i would
recommend checking out acre you know the
price of gold has been
all over the place uh you know that
fears of inflation
are getting more and more dramatic great
time to get invested in physical gold
but you might say michael
i'd love to do it i just don't have the
scratch on hand
gold is not exactly cheap what if i told
you you can get
investing in physical gold for as low
as thirty dollars a month thirty dollars
michael that that can't be well it can
be because the geniuses over at acre
gold
have come up with this uh ingenious new
product which
permits you to subscribe thirty dollars
a month when your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship physical acre
gold to
your house i've always loved investing
in precious metals it's done me very
well
and especially when you want to hedge
your investments against inflation
physical gold is a terrific way to do it
i really enjoy being
invested in acre gold head on over to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre is giving away a
gold bar yes a gold bar
to qualify tweet or post why you should
be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
getacreglol.com
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show this argument drives me nuts
this totally self-contradictory argument
that the guns that we have are now way
way too powerful and we've got to take
those guns away from the people the
founding fathers could have never
envisioned people having guns this
powerful
and also they're completely powerless
and they would do nothing against the
government so don't worry about it
the point of the second amendment of
course is to protect yourself
not just against burglars not just
against wild animals
but against people who want to do you
harm destroy your way of life take away
your liberties
and and harm you and your family whether
that person is a foreign invader or
whether that person
is a tyrannical government that is the
reason that the the
framers put the second amendment in our
bill of rights
the ar-15 is a common weapon it's the
most popular weapon in america and
it is a good weapon it's an accurate
weapon
when biden says if you want to go
against the government you've got to
have a
a f-15 or a nuclear weapon what are you
talking about
afghanistan i think it's the size of
texas right
it's not bigger than that and our
government has struggled to occupy
afghanistan in a
serious way for 20 years now and we're
basically going to give up and the
taliban is going to go back in
we have a very large country we have a
very
serious citizenry we have lots of people
who want to defend our way of life
you can't have it both ways mr biden
speaking of violence a much bigger story
that was trending all day yesterday
is of course the death of john mcafee
john mcafee the colorful software
pioneer the guy who had the anti-virus
software
that we all had in the 1990s and 2000s
john mcafee shows up dead
in a spanish prison raises a lot of
questions
what was john mcafee doing in a spanish
prison why would he kill himself and
actually
did he kill himself john mcafee was
was found to have committed suicide
as he was waiting extradition to the
united states ostensibly for
for tax fraud this is a little confusing
because john mcafee tweeted about seven
or eight months ago quote
i am content in here i have friends the
food is good
all is well know that if i hang myself a
la epstein
it will be no fault of mine john mcafee
talked about collecting
files on very powerful people and on
corrupt governments notably our own
government
he talked about having a kill switch he
got a tattoo
that said whacked he got a tattoo on his
arm
that said it implied the government is
trying to kill me
uh mcafee said this explicitly on
multiple occasions
and he said if i get killed just look at
the tattoo it says that i
got whacked then minutes after he was
discovered to have allegedly killed
himself
his last post on social media presumably
uploaded by a family member
was the letter q q now you remember
q was very important to the q anon
theory that the left talked about
incessantly for those
unfamiliar the daily mail says quote the
q anon conspiracy theory which came
about during the presidency of donald
trump
holds a wide range of odd beliefs
including
that trump was secretly battling
cannibalistic pedophiles who worship
satan
so i'm trying to find the conspiracy
part of that that is there any
is that it that's all that seems to me
like a conspiracy theorem
that seems to you just no i'm kidding
please don't take me off youtube
for suggesting that the liv i mean you
know risa aslan the guy at cnn that guy
was a
cannibal and you know you've got like
jeffrey epstein and some pedophiles and
the satan worship i mean that's just
before our
but no okay so anyway that conspiracy
theory
you know is it a little bit kooky so the
last thing this guy posts is the cue
on the one hand he lived a colorful life
he was a bit of a troll during his life
maybe this was just one
final performance that he was setting up
everybody to say if i kill myself it'll
be a
it'll be the government and it'll be a
conspiracy and then he actually does
kill himself and it leaves everyone
wondering i guess that's
one possibility or it's possible that he
really meant it when he said that
they're trying to kill me
they're i've i've lived under very
strange circumstances for many many
years at this point
and they then they did kill him he said
if i kill myself
you know it's not it's not real some
somebody offed me
a lot of people are saying right now
that the conspiracy theory
is that the man committed suicide that
so much
evidence is on the side of someone
offing him
that that the craziest conclusion you
could reach is that he killed himself
i i have one big question about the
epstein death
and first of all the fact that we refer
to him getting epstein right the fact
that he referred to himself getting
epstein
is evidence i think that something is
seriously wrong in our institutions
that we all just know that it that
epstein didn't kill himself
we all just know it or if he did kill
himself it was under very very strange
circumstances
where all the cameras just went out and
oh yeah the guards just fell asleep and
oh yeah the guards falsified records
and yeah oops and we're all just cool
with that we all just shrug and we say
epstein didn't kill himself well the
implication there of course
is that someone killed him someone went
into a prison and murdered him
and we're all just like well hahaha you
know that's that's the way the world
works
that implies oh yes the the possibly
billionaire pedophile ring
caribbean island owner who was hanging
out with the most
powerful people on earth who had a
former u.s president bill clinton
flying around on his plane dozens of
times
and who was close friends with bill
gates and close friends with the british
royal family with prince andrew and
close friends with lots of other super
powerful people
and seems to have had connections to
foreign governments ha ha
he just got whatever moving on that was
a fun meme
okay moving on so the the troubling
thing for me here
is beyond the death of jeffrey epstein
and beyond the death of john mcafee
the fact that we all just accept
this sort of corruption from our
government
or other governments even even if the
guys
actually killed themselves the fact that
we just expect this kind of corruption
from our governments and shrug it off
that is
a troubling thing but there are many
reasons to expect that level of
corruption
well beyond these two eccentric rich
guys
speaking of dubious suicides
hillary clinton is back in the news i'm
not i'm not saying i'm just
saying check for fingerprints
notably fingerprints like little tiny
fingerprints
maybe that looked like a lady who was
the first lady of arkansas and then
later in the united states
in 2009 according to leaked documents
right now
hillary clinton then secretary of state
warned
in a state department cable obtained by
wikileaks
that the work being done at the wuhan
institute of virology
could lead to quote biological weapons
proliferation concern this is according
to reporting from our pal jack posobik
over at human events
now we were told by hillary clinton and
by
so many other members of the liberal
establishment that
any suggestion that the virus was not
naturally occurring any suggestion that
it came from
the wuhan institute of virology any
institute that came from china period
was racist and awful and bigoted we now
have evidence that hillary clinton knew
that this sort of thing was going on it
was
sort of thing was being intentionally
developed
at the wuhan institute all the way back
in 2009 sounds like
clinton might not have been so honest
with us hillary clinton
tweets out last year quote the president
is turning to racist
rhetoric to distract from his failures
to take the coronavirus seriously early
on
make tests widely available and
adequately prepare the country for a
period of crisis
don't fall for it don't let your friends
and family fall for it this is because
trump was accurately and precisely
referring to the
china virus the virus that came from
china
you know like the spanish flu or ebola
or west nile so he was referring to the
china virus but whenever trump
identified the geographic location that
the virus would come from that was
considered racist and terrible
hillary clinton
years and years ago to 10 years prior
more
recognized that there were some
troubling things going on at the wuhan
institute of virology where they were
studying and beefing up coronaviruses
specifically for bio weapons
and she warned about this and then
nothing happened so if
hillary clinton is going to knock
anybody for not taking this seriously it
probably should be hillary clinton
herself or barack obama because nothing
was really done
and the u.s federal government continued
to fund and continue to work with the
wuhan institute of virology
up until this virus leaks and then they
cover up for them they help
the chinese government obscure the
origins of the virus and they continue
to do that today even as
evidence after evidence after evidence
mounds that that this came from the
lab and that this was engineered by
human beings our good old friend dr
fauci continues to try to obscure
the truth here speaking of the
coronavirus though
i've got some bad news for you well i've
got some bad news
but it's also news that just doesn't
matter at all
joe biden set a july 4th date for
hitting his targets on covid and finally
putting the virus behind us
and unfortunately according to jeffrey
saints the head of the white house
coronavirus response team
because of those damn utes because of
young americans refusing to take the jab
because of that we are not going to meet
that july 4th deadline
for americans 30 and older we have met
the president's goal of at least one
shot
that's right we have met the president's
70
goal for all u.s adults 30 and over
where the country has more work to do is
particularly with 18 to 26 year olds
the reality is many younger americans
have felt like covet 19 is not something
that impacts them
and they've been less eager to get the
shot
however with the delta variant now
spreading across the country
and infecting younger people worldwide
it's more important than ever that they
get vaccinated
can you believe those you know those
young people who
don't want to get an experimental drug
that you're not ever allowed to question
it's it's awful it's because of the
delta variant that's the indian variant
but we're not allowed to call it the
indian variant anymore the world health
organization said
that to simplify things we're no longer
going to call the the virus and the
variants
by the places that they come from we're
going to simplify it by
by using greek letters you know those
greek letters that everyone is so
familiar with
so this is really some terrible news
coming out of the white house we're not
going to reach the july 4th deadline
and my my big sophisticated take on this
is
um okay whatever who cares i
i certainly don't care no one cares even
i never cared i was never paying
attention to these stupid rules
any more than i had to any more than the
society
forced me to pay attention to these dumb
rules from people like fauci
and the liberal establishment that we're
changing their minds and changing their
guidance every single day
often contradicting themselves other
than when the society absolutely forced
me to i just ignored it i was basically
french kissing people on the street as a
way to say hello
i was basically licking doorknobs from
the beginning of this epidemic
feel great never felt better knock on
wood you know of course
people people can get sick but i'm
willing to take the risk i'm willing to
make a prudential judgment to go about
and live my life i assume a lot of
people are doing that too it's going to
be very difficult right now for the
biden administration
to say do not go out do not celebrate
the 4th of july
after just after encouraging people to
go
you know celebrate pride month to
finally
you know go out you don't need to wear
the mask all the time now after saying
that things are getting better after
saying that the
the vaccine is so effective for people
who've already gotten it
after inventing a new holiday they just
invented a new holiday last week
that people were supposed to go
celebrate but now they're going to try
to tell us but you can't
you can't go out on the 4th of july okay
i'm
not terribly concerned about that i
intend to eat hot dogs and drink beer
look at fireworks if there are any and
go ahead and live my life and i would
encourage you
to do that as well
now the kids are not all right not
because they don't want to get this
experimental drug that
doesn't stand to improve their health
really in any way
the kids are not all right because they
just don't want to celebrate
the fourth of july this according to at
least one survey a new survey
out of north dakota state university
discovered that the majority of
liberal-minded college students
are not proud to be an american
where at least they know they're free
the survey
was released by ndsu's chale institute
for global innovation and growth
focused on the role that colleges are
playing in promoting free speech
and tolerance of diverse views 57
percent of liberal students
said that they are not proud to be
americans while 73 percent of
conservative students said that they are
the majority of quote independent and
apolitical students 59
said that they are also proud to be
americans this
is a noteworthy survey
it in a way it doesn't tell us anything
we don't know
we know that the left does not
particularly care for this country
why do we know that uh because they
don't stand for the store spangled
banner because they
uh don't speak particularly highly of
this country they do promote
a historical anti-factual nonsense like
the 1619 project for instance
they're tearing down statues of george
washington and abraham lincoln
and thomas jefferson and they're putting
up new flags and
and new statues in their place so yes
not this is not surprising
at all not surprising that conservatives
do like their country if they didn't
like their country and they didn't want
to conserve something they probably
wouldn't be conservatives
but the key here i think are the
independent and the apolitical students
a clear majority of them are proud to be
americans
this is something i get to in my new
book which is available
as of the past couple days to order
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
radicals can only force a revolution
if they have some hold on the common
sense
otherwise they're just kooks and the
rest of us are going to laugh at them
the common sense tells people that they
still basically like
their country it's very strange because
the left
controls all the levers of power they
have
all of the institutions now they have
the elected government
and they have it entirely right they
have the house of representatives they
have the senate they have
the presidency the supreme court is
allegedly conservative but it doesn't
really operate that way
they have the bureaucracy obviously they
have the
the media and the universities and now
they even have the military we'll get to
that in just a second
so they control everything
as a matter of the levers of power and
yet
they can't get the people to go along
with their really radical ideas they
can't get the people to give up their
guns no matter how hard biden tries
they can't get people to trans the kids
no matter how hard
they try they can't get people to go
along with critical race theory for
instance
you've got parents showing up to school
board meetings it's some of the greatest
hope right now in the country
is ordinary parents are showing up to
meetings saying hey whatever this
nonsense is you're teaching my kids cut
it out and then the elites are actually
sneering at them and saying well you
don't even know what critical race
theory is oh you stupid irredeemable
deplorable rube and that's further
alienating the common people from
the desiccated mediocrities that that
claim to be the ruling class
so that is very very good
news that alienation i think is going to
increase and i think people are going to
dig their heels in on defending their
way of life not just it's not just about
the conservatives versus the libs but
it's crucially
about those independents and those
moderates you know
obviously right now i am not in my
studio for those of you who are watching
i am on the road i was hanging out with
my friend tim poole
last night and the rest of the gang over
there lydia and ian you can check out
that episode we were talking about among
other things my book
speechless thank you to everyone who has
ordered that book already
you know we there it is there's that
bell i was wondering if we had one in
this hotel room
you can get speechless right now it's
really jumped up the charts it has
cracked the top hundred on all of amazon
it has cracked the top 50 on
all of amazon and most of the top books
are actually cooked books and children's
books so in terms of real books i think
it's pretty high up there
uh thank you to everyone who has ordered
it you can i believe still get a signed
first edition i'm actually not sure uh
those are premiere collectibles if not
you can get the book
at amazon barnes noble uh wherever books
are sold i really want to jab it in the
eye
of the libs who put together the best
seller list so thank you for helping me
thank you for indulging me on that we're
going to be talking about censorship
tonight
we're going to be talking about what the
left is censoring
notably things in the news like the lab
leak hypothesis we're gonna be talking
about
the way that our words have been totally
transformed uh through things like the
the woke army ads we're gonna be talking
about everything on backstage so head on
over you get me
ben drew matt jeremy the god king boring
everybody over on backstage
streams at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
dailywire.com and on our youtube channel
do not miss it we'll be right back
aoc has something nice to say
about white men and republicans
those are two groups that she conflates
she thinks they're identical but it's
very rare that aoc would have anything
nice to say about either of those groups
and it's a little bit of a backhanded
compliment but it's
all because republicans caved on
our most sacred national feast day
the high point of the liturgical year
that wonderful holiday that's totally a
real thing and not just completely made
up by the libs
juneteenth this is pretty consistent
with i think the republican base
and it's whether it's trying to fight
against teaching
basic history around racism and the role
of racism in
u.s history to you know there's a direct
through line from that to denying
juneteenth
the day that we that is widely
recognized
and celebrated as the symbolic kind of
day that
to represent the end of slavery in the
united states you know
there's a direct through line between
that denial of our history and wanting
to understand the full scope of our
history
and celebrating the end a major end of
injustice
in the united states and i think it's a
it's a shame
but there's also plenty of wonderful
allies that helped us
pass this vote today despite that and so
i'm very thankful
to all of our colleagues um including
the white men in the republican caucus
that said okay fine we'll vote for this
or on this one too
but i think it just goes to show the
importance of teaching
his our history um warts and all
because it helps us appreciate the
justice and freedoms that we have today
isn't it so great that now finally we're
starting to learn about
slavery wait i had never heard about did
you know apparently in the united states
for some period of time
actually a relatively short period of
time compared to the rest of the world
including the many places today outside
the west that still have slavery
did you know we had slavery in america
you probably didn't know that
until juneteenth until we finally
stopped denying
juneteenth you know that thing that i
can
guarantee you aoc had never heard of
until like four years ago
now but now we can't we can't deny
we how can we kept denying it for so
long but now we know about juneteenth
what they are doing
is as i predicted
making juneteenth into the critical race
theory holiday
they're making juneteenth into the
radical progressive holiday
they're saying that if you celebrate
juneteenth
you you then must it is a logical
necessity
except insane ideologies like critical
race theory into the schools
you must accept the reframing of
american history by the 1619 project
that puts slavery at the heart of the
american narrative
you must accept these things and by the
way critical race theory according to
these guys
is no no more than teaching about
some of the warts in american his the
warts and all
the problem with critical race theory is
not that it exposes
america's true history warts and all
it's that it perverts and lies about
american history to only present the
warts
critical race theory says it posits
that america is intrinsically evil
that everything about america is evil if
you if you want to read up on this
you can either read there's a seminal
text
i think it's just called critical race
there it's a collection of essays by
people like kimberly crenshaw and other
pseudo intellectuals who who put this
idea together it's a derivation
obviously broader intellectual movements
such as critical theory but if you want
to if you want to understand it you know
just
get the highlights you can read my
current book book that is at now out
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
this uh theory posits there's one
seminal essay
the name of the author now escapes me
but you can read it in that collection
of essays
that says that forget about just the
races and forget about you know white
supremacy
for a second and just focus on the
economics
private property itself in the american
tradition
is intrinsically white supremacist
bigoted evil terrible must be done away
with
this is a movement by avowed marxists
usually to upend the entire american
system the entire western system the
entire system
of private property and that that is
what she is getting at there and she
says well thank you
thank you to those white men in the
republican party who are
finally doing that i do wish
that those white men in the republican
party who went along with this thing
had paid attention to the white men and
black men and women
and asians and hispanics and smart
people of all
stripes who are conservative who
recognize the danger of this
this sort of thing speaking of
republicans
the irs you'll be shocked to hear is
targeting
conservatives i know they've been doing
this more and more
since barack obama weaponized his irs to
go after
the tea party specifically to go after
his political opponents
and actually under obama the irs went
after an organization that i
was a member of called the friends of
aid this was a group of hollywood
conservatives
uh the obama irs kept trying to get the
book of membership it was a
tightly held secret because people would
be blacklisted very often
they just wouldn't work in show business
if
it came out that one was a republican
and
fortunately we never gave the book on
over to the irs well the irs now is
going after
a christian group because
the the irs is holding that the
christian group
is promoting the bible and the bible
is a republican party document i'm not
joking
i'm not joking on may 18th
the exempt organization's director over
at the irs stephen martin
denied the application for tax exemption
by a group called christians engaged
because martin said christians engaged
engaged in prohibited political campaign
intervention
and operated for a substantial
non-exempt private purpose and for the
private interests of the republican
party
okay well how is that well because
christians engaged said that they're
going to promote biblical teaching and
they're going to do that in the public
square and quote bible
teachings he lowercased bible by the way
he said
bible teachings are affiliated with the
republican party
and candidates this disqualifies
christians engaged from exemption
under irc section 501 c3
now i'm going to go back to what the
daily mail said earlier get back to john
mcafee posting
the letter q q on conspiracy theory is
this idea that trump was fighting
against satanists
well it would appear that the irs under
the biden administration is admitting
that they're saying that if you support
biblical teaching if you support
christianity then you are
identifying yourself as a republican
maybe now maybe to be fair to the irs
maybe they're saying look if you
promote overt satan worship that also
would not get you a tax exemption
because that would be a democratic party
activity
we're not going to allow either of those
things bible teaching
or satan worship to receive a tax
exemption but probably not actually
probably that's not what they would say
it's it's an amazing i won't even say
it's a tacit acknowledgement
that christianity has a political
dimension
that these days involves opposing the
radical left and its avatar the
democratic party
it's not tacit it's explicit now read it
up on the irs's website
they're not just going after protestants
by the way the federal government the
elected officials
are saying that if the catholic church
withholds the eucharist from joe biden
as joe biden is in a state of
unrepentant grave mortal sin
and he's also committing the sin of
scandal as the second nominally catholic
president
who is now coming out and saying that
uh he will continue to affirm the
constitutional
fictional right to abortion he'll
continue to flout church teaching on a
very important
issue if the church protects the
eucharist
against joe biden and his scandal they
could lose their tax exemption
representative
jared huffman says if they're going to
politically weaponize religion by
rebuking democrats who support women's
reproductive choice
then a rebuke of their tax-exempt status
may be in order
i'm glad that huffman came out and said
this
the threat against the catholic church
is disgusting the threat
against christians broadly speaking is
absolutely disgusting
but it's been going on for a long time
and i'm glad they're finally admitting
it
we do not have freedom of religion in
this country we are losing
our freedom to practice religion every
single day
we're losing it even in the language
that we use barack obama did this
very adeptly he changed the popular
phrase from freedom of religion
to freedom to worship and it sounds like
it's a subtle shift i guess it is subtle
but it's significant
religion is something that affects your
whole life you do religion
religion is not a private affair
religion is something you do
in public with people not just at church
on sundays but every single day of the
week
you have a private spiritual life when
you say your prayers at night or you go
into your inner closet to prayer
to pray but you also live your faith
publicly
and what the left says is no you have
the freedom
maybe to go to church on sunday maybe
but actually during the epidemic we're
going to shut those down but look you
still have the freedom to close your
eyes and pray quietly in your own head
as long as it doesn't affect anybody
and you're not allowed to continue to
practice your faith when you
for instance run your cake shop you're
not allowed to continue to practice your
faith
when you go to your place of employment
or
when you take up a role in the
government
but now that joe biden
is because he's so clearly violating
his own faith the bishops have to decide
or are we going to permit joe biden
to scandalously flout the faith here and
eat what we
hold to be the literal body of our lord
while he is in a state of unworthiness
and unrepentant
mortal sin or are we going to stand up
and defend it well if you defend it
folks
we're coming after you because we have a
state established church in this country
it is the state established church of
secular
progressivism it has its own liturgical
calendar it's got its own
secular saints it's got its own feast
days there's a new feast day called
juneteenth
there's a liturgical month it's called
pride month we're celebrating it right
now
and by the way this will have public
demands
this will have an actual caste system
which we're seeing
increasingly with the development of
critical race theory
with the castigation of white men as the
bane of all evil on earth
you know aoc so magnanimously is willing
to
acknowledge okay maybe wait white men
occasionally do something that's okay
but really i mean we should expect pure
evil from them
well at a seattle lgbt pride month
called taking black pride taking b
in parentheses l a c k pride
uh if you're if you're white you have to
pay more money
they're charging a reparations fee
they say ten dollars to fifty dollars to
keep the event
free of cost for black and brown
trans and queer people
that's pretty narrow how many black and
brown trans and queer people are there
two capitol hill pride organizers
complained and the seattle human rights
commission blast
human what the human rights commission
what is that uh blasted them on social
media
for complaining about charging white
people more money than black people
and uh included their unredacted phone
number and came out
the human rights commission decided to
dox people and put them in harm's
way they got
knocked for doing this now you're going
to see this more and more you were
openly seeing the talk of quote-unquote
reparations
which is not it's not really reparate
first of all we've already had
reparations in this country for a very
long time that's that was the entire
purpose
of the great society and the welfare
programs was to make reparation
for slavery a century prior
but it's not really reparations and this
wouldn't be reparations either because
that wouldn't be the end
you're telling me that okay we're gonna
we're gonna have a big reparations fund
and we're gonna give all the black
people
some money and we're probably gonna give
other races some money why i don't know
but that's being talked about
and we're gonna give recent nigerian
immigrants some money from who from just
white people how are you going to do
that in the tax code i'm not sure
and okay let's say you do it and then
we're all good right then it's totally
fine
something tells me that's not what's
going to happen
this is not just being enforced this
this racial caste system this
highly racial ideology is not just being
enforced
at the local level of some
kooky pride parades or something
this is being enforced by the government
that's what affirmative action is it
disadvantages whites and asians and it
gives advantage
to blacks and hispanics in college
admissions and elsewhere
it's also at the cultural level there's
a new movie coming out it looks really
bad i don't want to judge a movie by its
trailer because i haven't obviously seen
the movie yet
and the movie well take a listen
i'll take i don't want to color your
view take
is that a politically incorrect term am
i allowed to use that word anymore take
a listen
to the movie karen
tell me about your new neighbors they're
black
keeping it down if you don't comply i'll
tell the manager
somebody's taking home security serious
hi i am karen drexler i'm your neighbor
you need to be taking your trash cans
off the curb right when the trash is
picked up
is she nice yeah she's nice wait a
minute we have a
white entitled neighbor named karen
karen okay enjoy yourself there she is
slaving away in the kitchen
i've come across some very suspecting
teenagers can you please hurry up
please it's very aggressive yep i left
my wallet
with my id at home leave us alone we
didn't do anything
how the heck did you end up moving to
this neighborhood
next thing you know we have criminals
you take care of him and i
will take care of her would you mind
stepping out of the car
my office has uncovered some disturbing
information on
her and her brother
she doesn't like black people we have a
search warrant well i'm black
i know she doesn't like you either
karen this uh
doesn't look great people are comparing
this movie to get out
the difference of course is get out is a
good movie and this movie
is does not look very good right get out
is actually about this issue of
assimilation and this fear that when you
assimilate into a culture you lose your
soul
which is an interesting concept and i
thought it was a clever movie
this doesn't look like that this movie
uses a racial slur
which is karen some people are laughing
at the idea that karen is a racial slur
it is a i mean it's explicitly just a
derogatory term for white women
so i'm not i mean i'm using the term i'm
i've i've used some slurs i've used
just the other day actually in my book i
use a slur for italian americans
not not because i'm yelling it but just
in the context of describing it
i use one for the irish i use one for
asia i use a few i use them to point out
what these slurs are
karen is a racial slur there's no
getting around it it's one that
it's a mainstream one it's one that
we're all you're not really allowed to
say the other slurs and there's one slur
obviously you can you can never say
they would never make a movie with that
name but
the argument here is just preposterous i
think the reason
that get out rang true to people is
because
it's a legitimate fear it is not just
black people into a broader white
culture
but any group of people into any broader
culture there is a legitimate fear
of assimilation here the claim being
made
is that white women are committing
racist hate crimes against black people
that that's the defining epidemic of our
country and it's just
not true it just isn't happening we
talked about this
a few weeks ago on the show when you
look at the federal government's hate
crime statistics
you can look at the racial breakdown of
the offenders
and of the general population
52.5 of
hate crime perpetrators are
white and that includes hispanics
because hispanics have now been defined
as white so
just very slightly over half of the
offenders in hate crimes are white
73 of americans broadly including
hispanics who are now defined as white
are white so relative to their
percentage of the population
whites and hispanics are very very
unlikely
significantly less likely to be
committing these hate crimes
if you look at the percentage of hate
crimes committed by black people that
percentage is 23.9 percent
if you look at the percentage of the
population total that is black it's 13.4
so i'm not making any claim that it's
because of an intrinsic biological
reason or something that
whites and hispanics are relatively less
likely to commit hate crimes and black
people are relatively more likely to
commit hate crimes i'm just
i'm just telling you what the federal
statistics are i'm not saying we should
make
a movie with some black racial slur
about the way that hate crimes are
really perpetrated in this country
i'm not even saying the term hate crime
it should be a common term i think it's
a ridiculous term
because i don't think there are very
many love crimes
i guess that would be the opposite of a
hate crime i'm just pointing out
the reason that the trailer for karen
is risible the reason that we're all
making fun of it is because
while the ruling elites and the liberal
establishment tell us that the great
problem is white supremacy or
you know lebron james is telling us
black men can't leave their homes
without being hunted down by racist
whites we just all know it's not
true it's the furthest thing from the
truth when merrick garland the attorney
general comes out and says the
greatest threat to to us in america the
terroristic threat is white supremacy we
just know
that's ridiculous it's just absolutely
absolutely preposterous it is not true
and if you want to solve problems of
racial division if you want to solve
problems of crime which is spiking in
cities around the country
you need to be able to diagnose what is
really going on right
the first step to solving a problem is
admitting that you have a problem
and our culture will not do that i think
this is actually part and parcel
of this this broader alienation of
common
sense americans of all races of all
stripes of all appearances
from the group of of
silly mediocrities that that are
pretending to be the ruling class and i
suppose they really are the ruling class
in this country
they just they just have no right to be
and believe it or not the karen trailer
is not the sickest racialized video
going around the internet a white lib
mother
took to tick tock to explain why she
won't comfort her little baby girl when
she cries
because we should not play into quote
white woman tears even those of a baby
we'll have to get to that tomorrow
because we're out of time how's that for
a cliffhanger
stay safe out there don't get nuked by
joe biden i'll see you tomorrow i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden threatens to nuke
gun-owning americans chairman of the
joint chiefs general mark milley defends
teaching critical race theory in the
military
and democrats reap the whirlwind as
crime skyrocket that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen